what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the best villains in anime
who are largely defined by their
complete uselessness as actual villains
but despite sucking pretty hard at their
job of being effective villains we still
can't help but love them either because
they're hilarious because they spice up
the plot or because they have become
some of the most iconic memes that anime
has to offer in this video we'll be
examining several such villains and why
they stick with us despite being utterly
useless and if you end up enjoying this
video you want to see me make a part two
where I talk about even more useless
villains that we love just leave a like
share the video and give your
recommendations for which other villains
I should talk about down in the comments
below also don't forget to subscribe to
anime uproar and hit that notification
bell so you don't miss any of my future
useless uploads oh by the way if you're
thinking about complaining down in the
comments because I included his
Excellency Lord tweek Osama senpai
sensei in the thumbnail just watch the
video I assure you that my knowledge of
twe galore is beyond anything you could
possibly imagine let's start things off
with one of the most iconic villain
teams in all of anime a trio that most
of us literally grew up with and a team
known the world over for their nearly
complete uselessness as villains I am of
course talking about the legendary Team
Rocket from Pokemon
allow us to introduce ourselves James
lights surrender now or prepare to fight
[Music]
and more specifically the epic trio of
Jesse James and Meowth three villains
that have been with us in the Pokemon
anime since season 1 and even though
they did eventually become slightly more
competent as the story of the anime
progressed for a large chunk of the
series these guys have been top
contenders for the title of the most
useless anime villains of all time I
mean think about it in season 1 these
guys are defeated and humiliated by a
ten-year-old noob from an economic and
social backwater like Pallet Town a town
so isolated and weird that the lonely
people they are willing to let their 10
year old children venture out on a long
and dangerous adventure on their own
just so they could become uncomfortably
close with their mr. mime despite the
fact that Jessie and James are both
adults in their mid-20s with the
resources of an entire criminal
organization at their disposal they are
defeated by this 10 year old kid from a
creepy mr. mime loving town and by his
butthurt edge Lord Pikachu these legends
of villainy then decide to spend much of
their lives pursuing that same
ten-year-old boy and his friends with
the intent of capturing his beak achoo
because they apparently think that the
Pikachu is rare and would be valuable if
they could only steal it in fact trying
to steal Pikachu another rare Pokemon
but constantly failing miserably is the
trademark of this villain trio and if
you happen to be under the age of like
35 then the words Team Rocket's blasting
off again probably still haunt your
nightmares to this day
so why has Team Rocket continued to be
so iconic despite all their many many
failings other than the fact that Jesse
was like my first anime waifu ever and
the fact that james is a delicious meme
lorde extraordinaire
Team Rocket does have its strong suits
including their ability to make an epic
anime villain entrance the lyrics of the
Team Rocket intro are so iconic that
they are featured on genius.com I kid
you not a link to page in the
description if you want to check it out
Team Rocket also has iconic uniforms
that have been a favorite of cosplayers
and you can't help but love their
insanely stupid schemes on which they
tend to waste an incredible amount of
their organization's resources even if
they are adults with the intelligence of
a below-average Jake Poehler even if
they were constantly defeated by a
ten-year-old noob even though they keep
looking for rare Pokemon as if they
don't realize that Pikachu's are not
that freakin rare even if they are
supercharged and even though they're
rare Pokemon obsession doesn't seem to
cool them into the fact that their
companion is a pokemon who is so
intelligent that he was able to teach
himself how to speak and walk like a
human
Team Rocket still continues to have a
strong cultural influence on the anime
community and beyond as useless and
obnoxious as these guys are they have
blasted their way into our collective
psyche and we can't help but like Team
Rocket if for no other reason than for
their endless meme ability and Jesse is
still an underrated waifu in my opinion
I mean those leather boots though next
up let's talk about the most epic
villain brothers in JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure sure the d'Arby brothers get a
lot of attention because of their
absolutely epic battles against Jotaro
in part 3 but not everyone understands
the deep philosophy of the true stars of
part 3 the angle Boingo brothers these
two absolute Chad's are introduced as
members of Egypt's nine glory gods dio's
elite strike force tasked with
eliminating the Crusaders before they
can reach deal the younger brother
Boingo has a stand that allows him to
predict the future and the older brother
Boingo has a stand which allows him to
reshape his body in a way that enables
him to take on the appearance of whom
ever
he chooses you would think that together
these two stands can be extremely
effective and since ongoing Boingo are
brothers who are used to working as a
team
you wouldn't be blamed for thinking that
these two could potentially cause a lot
of trouble for our heroes the Stardust
Crusaders alas it was not to be as the
Oingo Boingo brothers proved to be
utterly useless as villains so much so
that the Crusaders didn't even realize
that they were being targeted by these
two they were pretty much defeated
without the heroes even knowing that
they defeated them and you may think
that this makes these two brothers just
a couple of terrible and ineffective
villains who are not even worth
remembering especially since JoJo's part
3 through so many different villains at
us within a short period of time but if
that's what you think you couldn't be
more wrong the ongoing go episodes are
probably the funniest episodes in all of
part 3 because of the hilarious hijinks
that ensue every time that only going
Boingo try to carry out one of their
bizarre schemes they start by using
Boingo Stan to see what will happen in
the future and then they actively try to
facilitate those events however their
interpretations of these faded future
events usually end up being way off the
mark and in hilarious fashion resulting
in such unforgettable scenes as I go
putting five lit cigarettes into his
mouth while impersonating Jotaro or
whole horse sticking his fingers up
polnareff's nose only going Boingo might
be useless as villains but boy are they
greatest characters and part three of
JoJo's just wouldn't have been the same
without these two epic gamers next let's
talk about everyone's least favorite
anime waifu the obsessive unstable and
wonderfully insane pop idol Misa Amane
aka Misa Misa from Death Note now Death
Note is famous for not having obvious
heroes and villains and a major theme of
the series is the true meaning of
justice but no matter which side of the
light versus El conflict Iran I think we
can all agree - Misa Misa is a villain
if you're on Team L then Misa is clearly
a villain because she is the second Kira
a criminal who is willing to kill
without remorse and if you're on Team
Light you might be tempted to think that
Mesa is on your side because she
worships the original Kira and she falls
in love with
right but the truth is that Misa creates
more problems for light than probably
anyone else aside from L himself she
worships Kira because he punished the
man who killed her parents when the
courts failed to do so and she is so
desperate to make contact with Kira that
she becomes the second Kira just to get
his attention her careless actions
provide the authorities and L in
particular with valuable information
about the true nature of Kira's
supernatural abilities and after that
Misa continues to make problems for
light by being obsessive naive immature
and jealous I've heard many fans of
Death Note complain about mises
character in general and as a villain
she certainly makes a lot of stupid
mistakes that put her beloved Kira in
direct danger but not so fast as
annoying as Misa can be we cannot deny
that she is a fairly early example of a
quality yandere character yes she is
insane and obsessive to the extent of
nearly ruining everything for light but
that is precisely the point of her
character Misa is a great representation
of what being in a relationship with a
real Yan that it would actually look
like I mean yeah having a wife who who
loves you so much that she would kill
for you without hesitation might sound
pretty cool at first but actually being
with such an emotionally unstable girl
no matter how cute and goth she is is
more trouble than you realize sure she
might shower you with endless love and
flattery but she is also unhinged
reckless impulsive obsessively jealous
and outright dangerous to everyone
around her including you we can call her
a useless villain we can call her an
annoying character but I would
definitely not call her a bad character
I think her overall character arc works
really well when we look at Misa form
what she is and what we take into
consideration her entire life story
including her tragic past her demanding
career which requires her to constantly
be in the spotlight her childish
personality and so on when you look at
all these factors together it's clear to
me that she is a well-written character
despite being a terrible villain and not
to mention that without a cute girl
character like Misa we would have had
pretty much no fanservice in Death Note
whatsoever
which is kind of why the writer of Death
Note decided to include her in the first
place I mean sure we all have Death Note
because it is a great psychological
thriller that features an epic showdown
between two brilliant strategists but
what this see
really be as good without acute goth
girl in stockings maybe probably but
still and finally at least as far as
this video is concerned let's talk about
the one and only Lord we go sama sensei
senpai from the seven deadly sins
at first glance Lord we go appears like
your average run-of-the-mill minor
villain who annoys the main characters
for a little while and then ends up
accidentally killing himself by
consuming demon blood you may think that
this is exactly why I'm including Lord
we go in this video but you would be
wrong
everyone who is familiar with the
expansive lore of the Lord we go meme
verse knows that the only reason why I
would include Lord we go in a list of
useless villains is because twe go is
not a villain at all he is useless as a
villain because his true role is far
greater than the role of any single
villain or hero could ever play Lord
twee goes true purpose surpasses worlds
and dimensions and he cannot be boxed in
by such simplistic characterizations as
villain or hero much like his disciple
Prince Clovis from Code Geass Lord we go
tricks us into believing that he is just
a one-note villain character who gets
off at the beginning of the story but
the clues to his true role and purpose
are everywhere could any man with a
moustache as glorious as two egos ever
be a minor useless villain no his
Excellency Lord we go is useless as a
villain only in as much as he is much
more than a villain in the first place
and this is why I had to include him in
this video not for myself but for all of
those viewers who may not be familiar
with the deep lore and mind-opening
philosophy of twe go and his followers
who are affectionately known as twe go
Slavens so I hope you enjoyed this deep
analysis and if you want me to do
another video on useless but still
beloved villains be sure to like and
share this video and comment your
suggestions for useless villains that
you want me to talk about down in the
comments also don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and click that
notification bell so you don't miss any
of my other useless uploads I want to
give a huge thank you to all of our
anime upper patrons for supporting our
work and making our work possible a
special thank you to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings ell
drous and on he'll cruise another
massive thank you to our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including baby ray ace
Ingrid ah al Olin Adam Maddy Mac
makoto-kun and Keylong and finally at
the very pinnacle of interdimensional
greatness a tier reserved only for
legends a massive thank you to Regan
Harrison and Lord naksan or disciples of
Lord we go himself if you feel that our
content provides value for you when you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these amazing people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]